7 millones de personas en senegal acuden
a las urnas este domingo para elegir a
los representantes de la asamblea
nacional del país donde los partidarios
del presidente macky sall tienen
actualmente la mayoría la oposición
espera que esto cambie se disputa en 165
escaños parlamentarios con mandatos de
cinco años cada uno 112 de ellos se
repartirán con base en la votación por
orden de llegada entre ellos 15 escaños
elegidos por la diáspora senegalés a los
53 restantes de cubrir mediante el voto
proporcional plurinominal en el que los
ciudadanos votan por listas nacionales
de candidatos los escaños se asignan a
los partidos en función del porcentaje
de votos que reciben el presidente ha
prometido nombrar un nuevo ministro del
partido ganador lo que está en juego en
esta votación es mucho los resultados
prepararán el terreno para las
elecciones presidenciales que tendrán
lugar en 2024